It was dark when you arrived at the office.
Rain hammered down on the windowpane, cold
as death.
Your therapist didn’t expect a frantic call
from you in the middle of the night, but he’d
learned to take such surprises as they came.
You called and drove over the second you had
the dream.
That terrible, terrible dream.
He was sitting at his desk.
When you entered the room, he gestured to
the couch, encouraging you to take a seat
and make yourself comfortable.
Your heart was beating so hard you worried
it might break your ribs.
Every time you blinked, you were getting flashes
of the faces.
Those vacant, grinning faces, with wide eyes
and mouths wrenched open, hanging slack.
You hoped to whatever God or Gods you believed
in to never see those images outside of a
dream.
“What’s been troubling you this time?”
He asked.
“I must admit...I’m getting a little worried
about you.
You seemed so frantic over the phone.”
You tried your best to settle your breathing
for long enough to speak.
At which point, you said the words you were
hoping you’d never have to say again.
“I had a dream about Cragglewood Park.”
You could almost hear the sigh your therapist
was desperately trying to conceal from you.
You’d been making so much progress, processing,
and working to move beyond that mysterious
trauma.
But then the dreams had come back - Just as
forceful and terrifying as they ever were.
Your therapist asked you to recount it, just
like he did so many times before.
But of course, it’s always the same…
In the dream, you were a child - probably
about six or seven - walking down a long,
cobbled path, surrounded on all sides by these
trees that looked like eerie amusement park
animatronics.
They had these big, rubbery faces, stretched
into eerie smiles, like something off the
cover of an old children’s book.
The Craggle Trees: You somehow knew, deep
down in your heart, that this was what the
trees were called.
This was, after all, Cragglewood Park.
Those words, in whimsical cursive letters,
were written on an aging sign somewhere deep
in your mind.
You could remember it as clearly as your own
mother’s face.
And you weren’t alone here in Cragglewood
Park.
There were other children, wandering down
that cobbled road like a lost scene from the
Wizard of Oz.
The trees grinned and gyrated and sang up
against a painted forest background.
Wait, was it painted or did it just seem somehow
unreal?
The memories were getting hazy here.
The same goes for the faces of the other children:
They were smudged out; forgotten.
Why were you here?
Why were any of you here?
And where were your parents in all this?
But those thoughts were blotted out by the
singing of those awful trees.
You couldn’t remember the words, but the
music was so clear: The haunting notes of
a calliope organ,
like a collapsing memory of a day at the circus.
You and the other children were all walking
in the same direction, as though in a trance.
What were you walking towards?
The calliope only got louder with every step.
A boy with a smudged-out face to the left
of you tried to speak, but his words were
muffled.
You couldn’t hear anything over the music
and the terrible, garbled singing of all of
the animatronic trees.
Then there were glowing lights and colors
as you approached the end of the road.
Something big, moving in time to the music.
A grand, old carousel, slowly grinding to
a halt to let on the next wave of children.
You and the others just stood there and watched
it.
Moments later, half of the crowd of assembled
children - the boy standing next to you included
- began to step onto the carousel.
The light got brighter and the singing got
louder.
By the time you reached the end of recounting
your dream to your therapist, you realized
that your cheeks were wet with tears.
You told him you’d do anything to get the
dreams to stop.
Anything.
Your therapist just nodded and made a note
in his journal.
“I’ll get in touch with someone who specializes
in this kind of thing,” he said.
“Try to get some rest in the meantime.
It can be detrimental to obsess about this
kind of thing.”
But how could you not obsess?
The second you got home, you did what you
always did after having another Cragglewood
Park dream: You went straight to the forums.
After all, the most frightening thing about
the Cragglewood Dream was the fact you weren’t
the only one having it.
A number of people had congregated on a niche
online paranormal forum to discuss their eerily
similar experiences.
Dreams filled with singing uncanny trees,
half-forgotten children, and the hazy horrors
of Cragglewood Park.
Each member of the forum alerted the others
whenever they had the dream again, and threw
any new information into the pot.
They came from all over the world - different
ages, backgrounds, and countries, making it
impossible that they’d all actually visited
a place like Cragglewood Park at some point
in their past - and really, the only thing
they had in common, other than the dream itself,
was the fact they were all only children while
in them.
None of them could explain the dream - Perhaps,
with almost eight billion people on earth,
it could be a coincidence that this handful
would have these peculiar dreams.
Perhaps that’s all it was: Strange dreams.
A few days later, a stranger arrived at your
door, telling you that they were referred
to you by your therapist: They’d heard about
the dreams, about Cragglewood Park.
In fact, they’d dealt with similar cases
in the past, and if you’d be willing to
answer a few questions, they may even have
a viable treatment for the strange dreams
that have been assailing you for years now.
What could go wrong?
Anything that could stop you from seeing those
awful tree faces would be good…
You relayed everything that you’d previously
told your therapist.
Every detail of the dream, the rough number
of times it’d recurred, and even the support
group for other sufferers that you frequented
online.
After you’d answered all of the stranger’s
questions, they told you that in order to
seek treatment for your strange dreams, you
would need only show up at a nearby building
and tell them who you are.
They told you that this is a highly confidential
and experimental procedure, so it would need
to be kept secret.
You sign a non-disclosure agreement and happily
submit to all their conditions.
You’ll do anything to stop dreaming about
Cragglewood Park.
Even agree to what you don’t know is Amnestic
Treatment from the SCP Foundation, who are
testing to see if erasing memories can suppress
the Cragglewood Park dreams.
You were among the first group of guinea pigs
for that experiment.
But hey, if it works, it works, right?
And for a few weeks, it did.
You submitted yourself to regular Amnestic
Treatment Sessions at a local Foundation front
business disguised as a legitimate medical
center.
You were skeptical at first - you’d tried
every therapy and over-the-counter sleeping
pill you could get your hands on.
You tried meditation.
Regression.
Hypnosis.
Positive subliminals.
Nothing had banished the haunting dreams of
Cragglewood Park.
Those trees, those faces, those awful, tinny
songs…
But to your immense relief, this new course
of treatment seemed to hold strong.
While taking the medication given to you by
the Foundation, you got your best nights of
sleep in years.
A whole new world of comfort and peace.
But then came a problem: There were supply
issues.
You’d need to take a few weeks off the course.
And just as soon as you stopped taking the
regular course of medications, the second
your head hit the pillow and you drifted off
to sleep, you were right back in Cragglewood
Park.
It wasn’t fair.
It just wasn’t fair!
Perhaps the nightmares would go on forever.
You’d spend every evening with those other
faceless children, always wondering.
“Who were they?
What happened to them?”
Little did you know, there were no supply
issues, the Foundation just wanted to test
the viability of Amnestic Treatment as a long-term
solution to the Cragglewood Park dreams - or,
as they dubbed them, SCP-2571.
Turns out, the Amnestics were only effective
when the subjects of SCP-2571 were actively
taking them.
Given that Foundation tests have estimated
around 0.05% of the world's population are
affected by SCP-2571, with that number possibly
on the rise by unknown means, consistent amnestic
treatment for all affected was deemed to not
be a viable solution.
But if it’s any consolation to you, you’re
not suffering alone.
The SCP Foundation has an online bot known
as I/O-MANDELA, trawling the internet for
any discussions relevant to SCP-2571.
They also have a designated task force, MTF
Phi-7, also known as "The Laughingstock",
to investigate and follow up on cases related
to the sinister Cragglewood Park.
The Foundation has conducted thousands of
interviews related to the subject, but only
three are appended to the file, containing
between them some revelations on Cragglewood
Park that reveal it’s actually far, far
worse than a childish bad dream.
Dr. Reiner, the Research Team Leader for SCP-2571,
conducted the first of the three pertinent
interviews about SCP-2571, investigating the
experience of one Rupert Duccasoux.
In many ways, Rupert’s Cragglewood Park
dreams were truly textbook ventures into this
nightmare of an amusement park.
He described venturing through the park, saying:
“I enter this theme-park.
It's like Disneyland, but smaller.
There's no rides; just this long, winding
road through the woods.
Everything's bright and colorful, like in
a cartoon.
And there's these trees all around me, but…They've
all got faces.
And they're singing.
They've got these dopey, cheerful looks, like
in one of those old time cartoons, right?
And they just sing and laugh and sing.”
Like all the other accounts, he reported approaching
a carousel with the other children.
Half of the children got on the carousel,
and he and the others began to leave.
At this point, Rupert became visibly distressed
while recounting the tale, and said:
“Just as I'm getting ready to leave, I see
something.
A tiny tree, sprouting up near my foot.
It looks up at me.
It's smiling, smiling with that big, dopey,
happy grin.
When I see it, that's when I start screaming.
That's when I wake up.”
When Dr. Reiner asked Rupert why he started
screaming, Rupert replied that the tree had
his face.
The interview concluded.
Next, Dr. Reiner spoke to Janine Yearling,
another victim of SCP-2571.
Dr. Reiner shifted his line of questioning
to the carousel specifically.
Ms. Yearling insisted that she never stepped
onto the carousel herself.
Some who did were smiling, others were crying.
They hugged some of the children that chose
to stay behind before they got on.
The more she described what happened, the
more distressed Ms. Yearling seemed to become.
She eventually broke down into mortified sobs
from the recollection.
When Dr. Reiner asked what was wrong, Ms.
Yearling said:
“One of the kids.
One of the kids that got on.
Why?
Why did he hug me?
I didn't — I don't even know who he was…”
Before breaking down into horribly desperate,
choked sobbing.
The final interview, and what it led to, was
the most eventful and disturbing of all.
Why?
Because this interview, conducted by Dr. Reiner
with Randolph Blair, was the first time that
a physical item in a subject’s home proved
that SCP-2571 may be much more than just a
malicious dream.
An old VHS videotape was found in Mr. Blair’s
attic, with the word “CRAGGLEWOOD” scrawled
across the top.
When the Foundation made Blair watch the tape
and asked him if he recognized any of the
images in it, he told them that he only recognized
them from nightmares.
He theorized that perhaps he’d been shown
the tape as a child, and it had traumatized
him.
The Foundation didn’t think that was the
case.
Dr. Reiner pressed on and asked him about
a few strange details: Like the resemblance
between himself and one of the two children
in the video, and the strangely vacant front-facing
bedroom in his childhood home.
At this point, Dr. Reiner realized that Mr.
Blair wouldn’t be forthcoming for much longer.
He decided to use that little time he had
left to ask Mr. Blair one more question: “Have
you always been an only child?”
That question would forever go unanswered,
but Dr. Reiner could now take an educated
guess.
The Foundation watched and analyzed the tape,
finding it eerily similar to so many of the
dreams that came before.
A young Randolph Blair and another young child
that the Foundation believed to be his brother
wandered through Cragglewood Park with the
others until they finally reached the carousel.
There, Randolph said a tearful goodbye as
his brother stepped up onto the carousel,
knowing somehow that he would never be seen
again.
And as Randolph tried to leave in a panic
moments later, he was cornered by another
horrifying Craggle tree, this time with his
brother’s face, singing in his voice.
Because Cragglewood Park isn’t a terrifying
dream.
It’s a terrifying memory.
Now go check out “Living Ice Cream Van SCP-1386”
and “Waldo Finds You - SCP-4885 - Find Him”
for more anomalies that will transform childhood
joy into heart-stopping terror!